THIS ANES BENCH MAY
HAVE GOTTEN A GOOD LOOK AT IT
TOO.
LET'S SEE. AY WAS OFFSIDE.
-ALSO TAKE THE GOAL OF  THE OIL
CAL HAS BEEN A LITTLE LACKING.
FROM TEUVO TERAVAINEN  AND
IN DECEMBER AS HE PLAYAY
HE WILL TRYING TO FIND HIS
AND NOW THEY ARE SHORTHANDED.
MIKE SMITH
WE KNOW WHAT HE HAS DONE
IMPRESSIVE.
MIKE SMITH.
WHAT RIGHT ON.THAT DRAFT.
1-0, CAROLINA.  TEUVO
TERAVAINIT . A
SMART SHOT.
HE LOOKS TO  THE PLAY WAS
OFFSIDE.
WE HAVE
DEREK WRONG McDAVID.
HE WALKS THE BLUE LINE.
HE TRIES TO
LL ANGLES.
IT IS
OF REBOUND ATTEMPT BY SUPPORT
ZACH HYMAN TRIED TO GET IT BUT
ANDERSEN HOLDS THE  AS MUCH TRU
LINE IN HIS CAREER.
>> Mike: THE SHOT
ANDERSEN MAKES THE SAVE AND
CAROLINA IS OUT WITH THE PUCK.
HE DROPS IT BACK.